considering it's practically the biggest
movie franchise in history it can be
pretty hard to keep track of what's
going on in the MCU and what's coming up
and while Marvel's next phases are still
shrouded in secrecy we do know a few of
the upcoming project slated for release
in early 2018 writer director James Gunn
confirmed that the third installment of
the ridiculously successful guardians of
the galaxy franchise would be on its way
in 2020 and a few months later he
announced via Twitter that a script had
been completed but an unexpected turn of
events threatened to kill the film
entirely amid a kerfuffle over some
years old highly inappropriate tweets
made by gun disney decided to part ways
with the director it was heartbreaking
news for fans not to mention the cast
who uniformly stood behind gun in a
joint public statement eventually it was
reported that the house of mouse were to
use gun script but would not bring him
back his director luckily for guardians
fans everywhere Disney announced in
March 2019 that gun would be rejoining
the Marvel Universe after all four
guardians of the galaxy vol 3
unfortunately the whole firing scandal
means the project's release date which
was originally set for 2020 is now up in
the air but that seems a small price to
pay for guns triumphant return to the
director's chair he may have been last
seen crumbling to dust in the arms of
Tony Stark at the end of Avengers
infinity war but the drama of that
moment was tempered slightly by the fact
that we all knew Tom Hollands Peter
Parker would be back - web sling another
day it was known well in advance of the
characters testing that Holland would be
appearing in more than one Spidey solo
film and sure enough it was later
confirmed that spider-man far from home
but take place after the events of
Avengers and games this sequel will see
young Parker going on a European
excursion with his classmates a relaxing
sojourn which turns not so relaxing when
Nick Fury and Maria hill show up to
enlist him in the fight against a team
of mysterious elemental monsters joining
the cast is Jake Gyllenhaal as Mysterio
a longtime spider-man nemesis in the
comics ooh if the trailer is to be
believed it's actually fighting on the
side of the good guys first at least but
fans know that Mysterio is prone to
whipping up all manner of intricate
illusions in support of his criminal
schemes so there's a good chance there
may be more to his relationship to spy
these new foes but meets the eye
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow has
popped up in no fewer than six MCU films
and that's exactly the kind of shady
past that would be right for further
exploration should Marvel choose to go
that route and although a Black Widow
solo flick has been rumored for years it
has finally been confirmed that we're
actually going to get one the film got
the green light in mid 2018 and Marvel
has already begun filling out its team
writer Jack Schaeffer was hired before
the project was even greenlit and after
meeting with over 70 potential directors
the studio finally settled on Australian
filmmaker Kate shortland Shortland
filmography isn't exactly extensive
she's perhaps best known for 2012 slore
a little scene but critically acclaimed
historical drama but if there's one
thing we know about Marvel it's that
they're out of left field directorial
choices nearly always turn out to be
blindingly brilliant in hindsight for
now fans can be assured that the project
is in good hands and all they can
reasonably ask is that Schaffer in
shortland Clewiston as to what really
happened in Budapest with 2016's Doctor
Strange a smash hit and the character
playing such a crucial role in the
conflict with a nose it seemed like a
no-brainer that the sorcerer supreme
would play a major role in the MC use
fourth phase and unconfirmed reports
citing an anonymous source from the
mirror suggest that Benedict Cumberbatch
has received a huge pay bump to star in
the sequel which may start shooting as
soon as 2019 but whether or not this is
actually correct the inevitability of
Doctor Strange 2 has been confirmed not
only by Cumberbatch but by Kevin Feige
as well when asked about continuing the
role by deadline Cumberbatch didn't
mince words he told the publication just
try to stop me that's all kind of lined
up as far as I'm aware but who knows I
mean you know the problem is how does he
get out of where he's at
but that's the only thing and while
doing press for Ant Man and the wasp
Feige confirmed to cinema blend that
Doctor Strange 2 would be set a number
of years after the first in December
2018 Hollywood Reporter even confirmed
that Doctor Strange director scott
derrickson would return to home the
project but of course were not likely to
get many more details about Doctor
Strange too until after phase 3 is
complete while a sequel based around the
sorcerer supreme hasn't been officially
confirmed Marvel isn't playing nearly as
coy about King 2 chala second solo
outing it doesn't have an official title
or release date but black panther 2 has
been officially confirmed by the studio
which isn't exactly a huge surprise
the original became one of the
highest-grossing films of all time and
Marvel's first film to receive a Best
Picture nomination at the Oscars not
only is the sequel officially happening
but Feige revealed to Entertainment
Weekly that the concept is already
coming together nicely he said one of
the favorite pastimes at Marvel Studios
is sitting around on a part one and
talking and dreaming about what we would
do in a part two there have been plenty
of those conversations as we were
putting together the first Black Panther
we have ideas and a pretty solid
direction on where we want ahead with
the second one writer director Ryan
Coogler is officially on board and while
nothing is confirmed it's expected that
the principal cast including chadwick
boseman Lupita Nyong'o
and Taniya Guerra will also return it's
even been rumored that Michael B Jordans
Erica monger could return in some
capacity
despite being left in no condition to do
so at the end of black panther in light
of the mega bucks that film made we're
likely to get additional details on this
highly anticipated sequel sooner rather
than later check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite MCU movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]